un bonsoir merci de répondre à nos
questions sur rt france vous fait office
d'exception dans votre partie puisque
vous êtes favorable à la pma pour tout
ce n'est pas difficile d'avoir ce genre
d'opinion dans un parti souvent aux
conservateurs sur les sujets de société
vous êtes un républicain progressiste
on va dire que je suis peut-être un ovni
en tout cas pour ma famille politique
aujourd'hui effectivement il est parfois
compliqué de se faire entendre sur les
sujets sociétaux puisque comme vous le
disiez notre famille politique est vue
comme conservatrice aujourd'hui j'ai le
sentiment que au sein de notre famille
politique plusieurs sensibilités exister
se font entendre
aujourd'hui en tout cas c'est pour moi
très bien pour un fait politique qu'il y
ait des gens qui soient favorables et
que d'autres n'y soit pas il faut voilà
il faut que le débat ait lieu en tout
cas je serai pleinement mobilisés dans
les heures à venir au sein de
l'assemblée nationale pour pour porter
la voix des gens qui y sont favorables
l'automne dernier seulement 12 des cent
quatre députés verts avaient voté en
faveur du texte
est ce que vous avez réussi à en faire
adhérer quelques-uns depuis notamment
sur cette question de la pma comment est
ce que vous expliquez cette frilosité
m'écouter il y as forcément des
séquelles du débat qu'il y avait eu en
2013 sur le mariage pour tous
aujourd'hui on a le n'a envie en tout
cas dont on n'a surtout pas envie de
revivre c'est un acte 2 de ce mariage
pour tous mais je vais revenir sur les
chiffres que vous venez de données sur
les deux députés qui avaient voté
favorablement pour le texte mais il ne
faut pas oublier toutes les abstentions
qu'il ya eu autour puisque sur le groupe
204 députés les républicains plus d'un
quart du groupe n'avait pas ne s'étaient
pas opposés alors moi je le lis cette
façon parce que comme vous le disiez par
rapport à cette fou c'est ce malaise qui
peut paraître dans le champ du politique
aujourd'hui plus d'un quart de notre
groupe ne s'est pas opposée donc ça
montre qu'il ya une certaine évolution
notamment comme je vous le disais depuis
l'épisode du maillage pour tous en 2013
alors les antilles perma se sont
manifestés à tout à l'heure
les opposants au texte dénonçant un
calendrier pour faire passer la loi en
plein été quand les rangs de l'assemblée
nationale sont clairsemés qu'est ce que
vous leur répondez
d'une part j'ai envie de dire qu'il n'ya
pas de catimini l'assemblée nationale
est ouvert pour tout le monde
il suffit de regarder l'agenda
parlementaire et prendre ses
dispositions aujourd'hui il n'ya pas
j'ai l'impression qu'on sort cet
argument parce que on a plus d'arguments
pour dire que pour débattre sur le fait
que nous soyons sûrs qu'ils soient
défavorables texte aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas de catimini il y a des gens de tout
horizon dans la sainte dans l'enceinte
de l'assemblée nationale voilà après
c'est peut-être ce et je trouve ça petit
effectivement on est en pleine période
estivale je le conçois mais le parlement
est là fonctionne donc aujourd'hui
travaillons et agissements emmanuel
macron avait fait de l'ouverture de la
pma toutes les femmes l'une des mesures
phares de son programme électoral les
associations notamment lgbt attend de la
majorité au tournant sur cette question
est-ce qu'il ya urgence à légiférer
selon vous bien évidemment qu'il ya
urgence il ya urgence pour plusieurs
raisons d'une part aujourd'hui il y a
une particularité qui rassemble toutes
les femmes qui ont déjà bénéficié d'une
pma pour tout c'est qu'elles ont les
moyens de le faire les moyens d'aller à
l'étranger de pouvoir payer se payer le
transport pour partir à l'étranger de se
loger sur place de pouvoir effectivement
faire appel à une clinique étrangères
tout ça fait un coup et aujourd'hui
toutes ces femmes elles ont cette
particularité c'est qu'elles peuvent se
payer le moyen de le faire donc il y as
a d'une part une égalité au social et
puis il ya des risques sanitaires tout
ça aujourd'hui j'ai appris tellement de
choses pendant cette commission spéciale
pendant toutes ses auditions sur la pma
pour tout d'une part des femmes dans un
tel désespoir de vouloir procréer on
était amené à acheter du sperme sur
internet et de se faire d insémination
artisanale à la maison est bien là je
dis que les sept heures doit intervenir
il doit intervenir tout simplement pour
légaliser tout cela de façon à ce que
cesser ces risques sanitaires
donc il y a effectivement plein de
facteurs emmanuel macron l'avez
peut-être effectivement mis dans son
campagne dans son plan de campagne pour
les présidentielles mais aujourd'hui
c'est faut mettre de côté la politique
politicienne il faut agir pour la
société est aujourd'hui moi en tant que
député me demande de faire quoi de faire
une loi juste équitable pour toutes et
pour tous et aujourd'hui j'ai le
sentiment que ça remet sur un pied
d'égalité tous tes femmes dernière
question maximino vous avez un autre
grand point de désaccord avec votre
famille politique c'est qu'a contrario
de la majorité des républicains vous
défendez le droit de mourir dans la
dignité et vous voudriez même revenir
sur la loi léonetti adopté à
l'initiative d'un député ump
qu'est ce que vous reprochez à ce texte
m'a qu'elle n'est plus adaptée à la
société d'aujourd'hui il est temps
d'évoluer à l'art jeunes la jeune juge
je suis pour effectivement une
amélioration des loi leonetti pour le
moment c'est encore un débat comment
dirais-je frileux au sens national mais
aussi pour l'ensemble de la société
c'est un sujet qu'il faut amener
doucement non il faut vraiment étudié
tous les aspects donc oui je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il est important de
réadapter cette loi aux besoins de la
société d'aujourd'hui
merci maximino d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
député les républicains de l'oise